free will isn't free it comes at a cost  if you believe that there is no free  will the cost is how to accept that the  idea of self doesn't matter anymore that  you just are that you are not the one  pulling the strings anymore you're not  in the cockpit of your experience you're  just floating in your experience but  maybe there is freedom in floating if on  the other hand you believe that there is  free will the cost is how to be a more  responsible human being the freedom to  exercise your will contains also your  responsibility to internalize morality  and its principles and strive for a  universal moral framework that will make  coexistence less arduous we are all  essentially part of a big experiment  called life it is our moral duty to be  more like the scientist and less like  the guinea pig in that experiment